[Musique]
ce n'est pas d'hier que la consommation
de viande fait parler d'elle
on attribue le trouble cardiovasculaire
notamment à une trop grande consommation
de graisses de viande etc
est-ce que c'est aussi grave qu'on veut
bien le dire c'est que si mal à 10 ans
est la principale cause de décès au
canada depuis des années les
scientifiques se penchent sur la
question est ce que manger de la viande
a un impact négatif sur notre santé la
réponse était claire oui jusqu'en
septembre dernier il a une nature qui
est venu bousculer en plus se contentant
publiée par l'american college of
physicians les résultats indiquent qu'en
réduisant à trois portions par semaine
notre consommation de viande rouge on
diminue les risques de mortalité par
cancer à 0,7 pour cent un risque trop
faible selon eux pourrait être
significatif c'est sûr que la nouvelle a
été rapidement reprise par les grands
journaux de ce monde les grandes chaînes
de digne de ce nom
moi j'ai un gros problème avec les
méthodes ce que voudrait que tous les
groupes d'experts ont critiqué cette
étude que ce soit les médecins on
organise ce moment c'est la santé un des
co auteurs de cet article a omis
curieuse marque de décrire qu'ils
avaient des intérêts commerciaux
cette fois ci avec l'inde
bref ces auteurs là n'ont aucune
formation en nutrition
ce sont des statisticiens donc que font
parler les chiffres
chantal blais est une spécialiste en
prévention cardiovasculaire oui le
danger avec ses résultats d'études là
qui font des tempêtes médiatiques c'est
que les gens vont rester avec le
souvenir que finalement on peut manger
de la viande on peut manger la
charcuterie tentes ont vu ça peut
vraiment d'impact sur la mortalité
je pense que c'est là où il faut mettre
les pendules à l'heure on peut
littéralement prendre cette étude faire
une belle boule de papier avec et la
mettre aux vidanges la docteur julie
st-pierre participe à de nombreux
comités d'experts scientifiques
internationaux dont l'american heart
association
il n'y a plus de doute sur la base de la
science objective exemple de biens
commerciaux qu'il y a un lien à faire
entre la consommation de viande rouge de
viandes transformées rouge et le risque
de mortalité cardiovasculaire ou
parcours de cancer
manger des charcuteries augmente de 17%
de risques de mourir d'un cancer
colorectal ou d'une maladie
cardiovasculaire ce taux est à 10%
quand il est question de viande rouge
comme le boeuf le porc ou bling faut se
rappeler que la viande rouge on en mange
énormément l'amérique du nord
on peut parfois manger une à deux fois
par jour et souvent ça peut occuper la
moitié de notre assiette
l avion être conscient des choses
intéressantes comme des protéines comme
ce faire mais elle est également une
source importante de ses dires saturer
les gras saturés qu'on trouve aussi dans
les produits laitiers huile de palme et
de coco sont particulièrement pointés du
doigt par les chercheurs
les gras saturés il faut les manger avec
une certaine prudence de façon beaucoup
plus occasionnels ont contribué à lattes
hérault ce féroce qui avait aussi cement
de nos artères et l'athérosclérose peu
probantes et le risque d'événements
cardiovasculaires des factures n'y a
qu'un c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
souhaite à personne
il faut également se méfier du
cholestérol présent dans les viandes
rouges le cholestérol alimente avanandé
bien plus grâce va définitivement
augmenter le taux de lipides sanguins
ces lipides là un potentiel carcinogène
[Musique]
la cuisson peut aussi avoir un impact
sur votre santé
lorsqu on cuit la viande on a des très
haute température par exemple quand on
évoque rire avec war vecchio dans la
poêle à très haute température
il peut se produire des produits
chimiques qui sont cancérigènes des
hydrocarbures pour faire des grands noms
mais qui peuvent également augmenté
l'instance de cancer on parle ici de
cancer de la prostate du côlon du sein
et du pancréas l' agence de la santé
publique du canada recommande de limiter
l'exposition aux viandes carbonisés si
on allait tout de suite aux
recommandations
qu'est ce qu'on voit qui est qui est
important à faire bon on voit que
premièrement de diminuer légèrement la
consommation vient avec autant de
preuves scientifiques sur les dangers de
manger viandes rouges et charcuteries
faut-il les bannir de notre alimentation
peut-être mangé bio manger un qualité
des gangs sont plus maigres de façon
beaucoup plus occasionnels et de façon
diversifiée afin de maintenir une bonne
santé cardiovasculaire de manger moins
de viande je pense que c'est intéressant
parce qu'on va suggérer c'est de limiter
à peu près à deux ou trois repas de
viande rouge par semaine pour chaque
repas c'est environ 120 g de viande donc
l'équivalent de jeux de cartes et on
suggère vraiment d'éviter les vient
transformer le plus possible donc de ne
pas manger tout ce qui s'appelle
charcuterie aux dogues
bologne et compagnie
une augmentation des protéines végétales
une diminution de la consommation des
viandes rouges et associés aussi à une
diminution du risque cardiovasculaire
ceci dit nos enfants du québec sont
beaucoup plus ouverts ce sont des
citoyens du monde
ils sont déjà beaucoup plus alerte que
nos générations les générations
précédentes avoir une alimentation qui
est plus simple
[Musique]